well this country is set to have its
next census in 2020 that's Dylan ated in
the Constitution we have to every 10
years unless policies change the census
will be counting illegal aliens the same
as everybody else the census hasn't
asked about citizenship status since
1950 meaning that a lot of states get a
boost to their congressional
representation because of the illegal
immigrants in their state this is a
problem it's not democratic Kansas
secretary of state Kris Kobach says it
is time to change that and he joins us
tonight the secretary thinks are coming
on great to do with you so the
Constitution says you have to have a
census to apportion congressional
district yep and so the only people
whose information matters are citizens
so it matters whether citizens are not
correct it absolutely does I think of it
this way there are seven hundred and ten
thousand people per representative in
Congress but if you live in a district
like Maxine Waters district out in
California
probably half or more of your district
is illegal aliens and so you may only
have 350 citizens voting in your
district those citizens vote that counts
twice as much as my voter your vote if
you live in a district that doesn't have
tons of illegal aliens so you have vote
dilution where some people's vote
matters more than others because they
have tons of illegal aliens in their
district but wait a second I thought the
Liberals are always yelling about how
every vote counts every vote should
matter the same as any other vote yeah
why would they before this well I think
it's the it's a dirty little secret that
they don't want to talk about and you're
absolutely right the 1964 decision of
the Supreme Court Westbury versus sander
says voting dilution is unconstitutional
you cannot have one congressional
district where there are fewer voters
that are in another district and because
of illegal immigration we have crazy
disproportional extraordinary numbers
where you know in a Midwestern seat you
might have to get a hundred and twenty
thousand votes to win your election in
in Walters district you might only need
40,000 so what's it I don't understand
the argument I mean the answer is really
simple just check a box are you a
citizen or not you allowed to vote
legally that's the whole point of the
census exactly what's the argument
against that the only argument against
it that I have heard is a really lame
one they say that people will be afraid
to answer the census form if it has the
citizenship question which is ridiculous
first of all and and secondly we already
asked the the citizenship question on
the American communities
which about 1% of the population gets in
the Census Bureau asks that it's an
ongoing survey the Democrats never
complained about that only when suddenly
we talked about putting the citizenship
question back on the census do the
people on the Left start why should we
care if people who aren't allowed to
vote in our elections are afraid to
answer a census which is designed to
apportion congressional district well
there's that too if you're if you're
illegally in this country you we
shouldn't be considering you a resident
anyway because you could go home at any
day you could be deported any moment so
why in the world would be we'd be
worried about counting you why would
your feelings matter more than a fair
election exactly and it's not just fair
elections to government's need this
information I highest Secretary of State
cannot accurately calculate the the
registration rate the percentage of
eligible people who are registered
unless they know how many citizens I
have and right now I just have an
estimate I don't have real numbers that
is crazy
secretary of state Kris Kobach of Kansas
thank you for joining us my pleasure to
see you